the Hydra commonly referred to as the
lernaean hydra or the hydra of learner
is a serpent-like monster from Greek
mythology depending on the text the
Hydra was considered to have between
three to nine heads the biggest of which
being considered immortal the Hydra was
one of the offspring of Typhon and
echidna otherwise known as the father
and mother of all monsters from his
birth
Zeus his wife Hera trained the Beast to
attack and destroy anything that fell
beneath its gaze and for years it
ravaged innocent villages as well as
being able to regenerate his heads the
hydras blood was toxic meaning that a
bite from the Beast was deadly toxic gas
from its breath had engulfed the lake
meaning that villagers could not enter
and will cut off from their only water
supply many believed that lake Lerner
was indeed the entrance to the
underworld and the Hydra its guardian
Heracles more commonly known as Hercules
was sent by King Eurystheus to slay the
Beast upon arriving Heracles had to
cover his face of a piece of cloth to
not inhale the toxic gases Heracles
enlisted the aid of his nephew lawless
however despite this assistance the two
would still struggle to slay the Beast
for every time Heracles cut off one of
its heads two would grow back in its
place
eventually the two formed the plan to
slay the Beast
Heracles would continue to cut off the
hydras heads and with the use of a
firebrand Lawless would cauterize the
wounds therefore stopping the
regeneration process of the hydras heads
as the tides of battle began to turn
Hera in fear for her beloved Hydra sent
a giant crab to aid it in its fight
against Heracles and lawless however
this was to no avail as the two made
short work of the crab and continued
their fight against the Hydra the final
head of the Hydra was indeed immortal
and could not be killed using
conventional weapons however Heracles
possessed a golden sword given to him by
Athena which allowed him to cut off the
final head
despite being removed from its body
the immortal head of the Hydra was still
moving and alive
Heracles dipped his arrows in the
poisonous blood of the Hydra as he knew
this could help him of his upcoming
trials once Heracles had extracted all
the venom he needed he took the
wriggling immortal head of the Hydra and
buried it deep underground away from its
body so it could never regenerate once
the Hydra had been slain Hera made both
the Hydra and the giant crab
constellations so they could be
remembered forever I think we can agree
that with the ability to regenerate its
poisonous blood and it's multiple deadly
heads the Hydra was a formidable foe for
anyone if you've enjoyed this video then
please go ahead and leave it a like
consider subscribing if folklore
mythology is something that interests
you if you have anything you'd like to
discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please go ahead and let me
know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained
[Music]